منذ عام
1967 تعرضت نحو 177000 فلسطينيه للاعتقال
والاسر ولكل واحده منهن قصه معاناه ونضال
في مواجهه السجن والسجان وقصه صمود في وجه
الاحتلال نتساءل حقيقه عن مرح هل لها من
اسمها نصيب هي التي تبلغ اليوم 24 عاما
اعتقلت وعمرها 16 عاما في طريق عودتها من
المدرسه اتهمت بعمليه طعن و اخترق جسدها
الغض انذاك 14 رصاصه ماذا فعلت السنين
بمرح مرح طفله وما زالت اصلا طفله صحيح
عمرها صار 24 سنه لكن ما راح تخلت عمرها
16 سنه مع انها طفله وكانت بحاجه لتكون
موجوده مع اهلها مع اخوتها بحاجه انه
نعتني فيها وهي مصابه ب 14 رصاصه في ايدها
بس للاسف الاحتلال ما بميز بين اسيره بين
شاب بين طفل ف ما راح هي هي مرح الكل
بيشهد بضحكه مرح اللي دائما دائما معبيه
القسم هذا دليل انه مهما يحاولوا يعني
يهزموا عزيمه الاسيرات او الاسرى ولكن
عزمتهم دائما بتكون اقوى كل ام يعني حتما
لا تتمنى ان ترى ايا من في الذات كبدها
وراء السجون لكن تجربه الاسر لقضيه مثل
قضيه فلسطين كيف ترينها ما رح كاسير هذا
شرف عظيم يعني لاي عائله فلسطينيه موجودين
نحن في مدينه فيها احتلال ما بفرق بين اي
احد لكن كام اكيد بتمنى انها ما رح تكون
موجوده معنا تكمل تعليمها تعيش معنا
تفاصيل حياتنا اللي بالضبط صار لها مرح
سبع سنين ونص موجوده بالاسر كبرت وهي مش
موجوده معنا اخوتها كبروا وهي مش موجوده
معنا ما قدرت تكمل تعليمها للاسف لحد الان
كبرت وهي مش موجوده معنا اخوتها كبروا وهي
مش موجوده معنا ما قدرت تكمل تعليمها
للاسف لحد الان مرح المفترض كانت تكون
خلصت دراستها الجامعيه فهي التفاصيل كلها
قد ما هي بتوجع قد ما انه بتخفف انه مش بس
م رح موجوده بالاسر لحالها في معها كثير
اسيرات كانوا قاصرات وصار لهم مع بعض سبع
سنين ونص بس ما بقدر اقول الا غير انه هذا
مصيرنا للاسف في مدينه القدس وفلسطين عامه
ولكن اكيد بتمنى ما رح ترجع لحضني ادير
بالي عليها مثلها مثل اخوتها وما رح
بالنسبه لي كانا وابوها واخوتها مرح لسه
هي الطفله اللي طلعت من البيت وعمرها 16
سنه ونص ما الذي تنقله لك عن ظروفي اسرها
وتجربه اخريات معها ايضا في سجون الاحتلال
كثير زياره متعبه نفسيا انه بتروحي بتزوري
بنتك بتقضي معظم النهار وبالاخر على 45
دقيقه ما بتتخيلي قديش بكون الوضع صعب انه
انت متشوقه تشوفي بنتك بعد غياب بشهر او
اسبوعين من الزياره الاخيره وبتترك
وبتروحي على البيت فاخر نظره دائما دائما
بتكون كثير كثير صعبه طبعا ما رح كونها
هلا ممثله الاسيرات اللي هي معناتها متحد
باسم الاسيرات مع الاداره اللي بتنقل كل
متطلبات الاسيرات اللي بتنقلها لاداره
السجون نحن كثير فخورين بمرح بصغر سنها
اللي هي باعتبارها لاصغر ممثله اسيرات
اللي صار عمرها 24
سنه ومرح للاسف لحد الان ما تلقت اي علاج
اقر الدكتور انها مرح بحاجه لعمليه لانعاش
الاعصاب عندها لانه هلا مرح في طريق تلف
الاعصاب عندها لانه بعد سبع سنين ونص مرح
ما تلق العلاج اللازم فالفتره الباقيه
لمرح للاسف مش لصالحها بالمره ولكن اداره
السجون للاسف منعت العلاج و وخبرتها انه
هي مش بحاجه للعلاج وهذا طبعا من سياسه
الاهمال الطبي المتعمد داخل السجون
الاسرائيليه كلياتها خلال السبع سنين ونص
مرح دائما عندها الاوجاع صيف وشتاء رطوبه
البحر كثير كثير بتاثر عليها مع كل هذا
مرح دائما من الصبايا اللي ما بتشكي دائما
بتقول الحمد لله رب العالمين انا منيحه
لكن لما يطلعوا من السجن وبتم التواصل
معهم ببروني قديش ما راح بتحس في وجع في
ايدها بس هي دائما من الصبايا اللي بتكابر
واللي دائما بتحب الاداره تشوفها شامخه
قويه من مره ما بتحب تشوفها
[موسيقى]
ضعيفه